el policía que mató a Ana él permanecerá
en prisión un juez decidió este jueves
prolongar su Estancia bajo recomendación
de la fiscalía el ente acusador publicó
un documento detallado que resume la
investigación en torno al día en el que
el adolescente murió sobre todo describe
los eventos que llevaron a su deceso a
las 7:55 en el suburbio parisino de
nantek dos policías motorizados
intentaron detener anael pero el se negó
a continuación una larga y peligrosa
persecución el condujo a una alta
velocidad con aceleración y repentinas
basándose semáforos en rojo y cruzando
intersecciones a máxima velocidad y sin
precaución por los peatones incluso dio
un volantazo hacia uno de los oficiales
de policía cuando los policías
detuvieron el auto se ubicaron en el
lado del conductor y un oficial puso su
mano dentro del vehículo y comenzó a
golpear anael esto de acuerdo con los
dos pasajeros el otro oficial apuntó con
su pistola y disparó pero los policías
relataron una historia diferente en el
reporte policial inicial ahí aseguran
que uno de los uniformados se puso
enfrente del auto para detenerlo y que
el conductor intentó escapar pasando por
encima de él el policía que disparó
relató posteriormente a los
investigadores por qué lo hizo él
decidió abrir fuego para prevenir que el
conductor golpeara a alguien o cargara
contra su compañero el abogado de la
familia de nael asegura que este policía
dio un testimonio falso a los
investigadores Mientras que el abogado
de la gente argumenta que su cliente no
debería estar en la cárcel